it depends on how much capacity for
truth the person can have because there
are certain things that are subjective
and then there's certain things that are
not subjective at all and so just like
how you were saying earlier like is this
predetermined it's both you get random
variables called chaos and then you get
ordered which was predetermined put them
in a little bag like two cats and you
watch them fight and see what happens
there is always that Randomness that
comes out of that construction so
there's predestined mixed with what are
you going to do next between those two
is how we live our life how a person can
harness enough of their free will to
enter their Dharma is by first
understanding
that those two are in harmony with one
another we could look at it as the
subjective and the objective having a
higher capacity for the objective
meaning the objective truth of the world
having a larger capacity for truth will
allow a person to now go oh wait a
second maybe that wasn't my purpose